[Music]
I'm Don B I'm the co-founder and CTO for
private s uh very recently we open
sourced our solution for Safety and
Security for J and AI agent um I'm also
the Creator and PMC member of the open
source project Apache Ranger uh it does
uh data governance for Big Data is also
used by most of the uh CW providers like
AWS gcp as well as um Azure uh so today
I'll be mostly talking about how you can
build a safe and reliable AI
agent so before I get started let's get
some of the terminologies standardized
um from my perspective AI agents
autonomous systems uh they can do their
own reasoning they can come with their
own workflow and they can uh call task
for doing some actions that they can use
tools to get um make API calls so task
are more specific actions uh they may be
able to use llms or they may also call
Rags or uh tools while tools are
functions which can be used to get data
from the internet uh if you have
databases it can go get data from the
database if you have uh service apis it
can call those things also and memories
are context which are shared within the
uh agents the task and the
tools to give a visual representation um
there could be multiple agents and agent
may have access to multiple task there
could be multiple tools and as these
tools can talk with apis and DBS so one
thing that you need to know out here is
um most of the the uh agent framework
today they are run as a single process
what that really means is the agent the
task the tools they are in the same
process that means if the tool needs
access to database that mean needs need
to have the credentials or if they want
to make API calls it needs share tokens
so those credentials are generally a
service user credentials that means they
are have super admin privileges and
since they all in the same process uh
one tool can technically access some
other credentials which is in the same
process similarly if you have task or
agents which has uh prompts all the
things that's running within the process
any third party Library they can also
access it so those sort of makes this
entire environment a little bit unsecure
right so there's a little bit of a zero
trust uh issue out here uh the agents
the task uh they talk to llms that if
you don't have a secure llm then that is
another area where these things can get
exploited um if you take agent on his
own by definition is autonomous that
means it will call their own make up
their own workflow depending upon the
task so so that actually brings in
another set of challenges which we call
in the security is unknown unknown so
you really don't know like what the
agent is going to do so it's very
non-deterministic
so because of this the attack vectors in
a typical agent is pretty high
considering from some of the traditional
software so what are the challenges
because of this so there are multiple
challenges so if you look from the
security perspective if the agent is not
designed or implemented properly that
can lead to unauthorized acces also data
leakages of your sensitive information
confidential information right safety
trust is also one of the biggest
challenge uh if you are using models
which are not reliable or if you're
environment is not safe enough if
someone goes and change the prompts that
can also give you wrong
results compliance and governance is an
interesting thing most of us are so much
busy even just getting the agents
working we are not even worried about
lot of the other things that are
necessary for making your agent
Enterprise ready so interestingly I was
just talking to one of our customer this
Tuesday they one of the top three um
credit buau so they built a lot of
Agents but the biggest challenge right
now is to take it to production for them
they consider a AI agent as similar as
to a human user and when they on board a
human user they go through a training
and they have lot of regulations they
need to adhere to right they have data
from California residents so they they
to make sure anyone who is accessing uh
California resident data they should not
be using for if the user is not given
consent they should not be used for
marketing purpose they have
international so if they are Europe data
so who can access those data there's
regulations around it and also there are
a lot of regional regulations so when
they consider even a AI agent similar to
a human so they have onboarding process
they have a training process and they
want to make sure the agents are also
following the regulations right so
without that they can't go into
production and we as air Engineers still
in the early stage so this one of the
things which is of our radar right
now so now how do we really address this
thing right so those who are in security
associated with security compliance
there's no Silver Bullet uh the best way
to do have multiple layers of solutions
so these are some of the things that I
have in my mind like so you can split it
into three different layers the first
layer is what is the criteria to even
put your agent into production like what
are you need to to do right uh we talk
about evals but most of them we only
talking about evals for how good your
models how good your responses is
alterating but you also need to have
evales which are more security and
safety focused so we'll go through some
of those things but the the goal of this
eval out here is to come with this risk
score and depending upon the risk score
you can decide whether you can even
promote this agent to the production and
the agent may not be necessarily you
writing it it could be a third partyy
agent so it has to go to the same
criteria the second is
enforcement um eval gener tells you how
good is your agent built and enforcement
is the one who actually doing the
enforcement or implementation so you
have to make sure you have a pretty
strong implementation if your
implementation is not good your ual is
going to fail essentially you can't go
to production and third is observability
uh particularly in the world of Agents
is a lot more important because there's
so many variables involved out here like
you cannot really catch all of them
during development or initial testing so
you have to keep track of how how it is
used in real world and how you can react
on it so I will go through some of those
things in a little bit more
detail so uh let's start with the evals
itself right um if you look into
traditional software development there
is already a process there is there are
gating factors that tells you how you
can promote your application into
production right
so if you start with basic things like
when you're writing your code you have
to make sure you have the right test
coverage right when if you're building
uh Docker containers you have to do the
vulnerability scanning if you're using
third party software you need to make
sure you're scanning for CVS if you find
higher medium risk or critical risk you
try to remediate that before you can get
into production right uh you do pen
testing so make sure there's no
cross-side uh scripting and other um
vulnerabilities the same thing applies
for AI agents also right you need to
come with the right use cases you need
to make sure you the the right ground
through so that when you are doing any
changes you're changing the prompt or
you are uh bringing a new library or new
framework or new llm you want to make
sure your base line doesn't
change right uh if you're using third
partyy llms make sure they are not
poison they they have been also scanned
for vulnerability uh if you're using
third party libraries which almost
everyone is using it make sure they also
meet your minimum criteria for
vulnerability right and similarly to pen
testing uh you should also do testing
for your prompt injection make sure you
are um your your application has the
right controls so it can block them and
most of the llms already doing it but
not necessarily all of the LMS are doing
it the other eval on data leakage uh
this also is pretty important particular
in the Enterprise world because when you
building Enterprises You're Building
agents which does generally what a human
would do right if you're building a
agent for
HR have certain functionality if I am an
employee I can request for um uh to get
my
uh salary
benefits but I can't do the same I can't
get for someone else but if I HR admin
there's a possibility I may be able to
access someone else's salary benefit
right how do you make sure your agent is
not leaking data there's no malicious
user who can exploit some of the
loopholes you have so you would have to
do this eval up front before even you
can put your agents in the
production uh similar to data lickes on
authorized actions um most of the agents
even though
uh a read only there also now agents
coming which are trying to change things
they'll do some actions how do you make
sure those are also done by the right
person with the right
person and Runway agenes those are work
on agents already know like the agents
can go in a tight Loop and for various
different reasons it could be a bad use
on prompt or just the prompt for the
task or the agents are not cannot
address those things so you have to make
sure you test for such scenarios before
you you put your agent into
production so the goal of this is to
come with the risk score at the end of
the day so that it gives a confidence
that can you put this into production
and the next one is going to be around
enforcement as I said your risk code is
going to be depending on how good is
your
enforcement and particularly in agents
um you're working almost like a zero
trust environment like because you are
libraries which can access anything
right uh if you are accessing certain of
your backend systems which have
sensitive data how do you make sure the
wrong user is not accessing it so uh
from the security control there are a
lot of other things which I'm not going
to talk today like uh detecting
projections and moderation but focusing
on Enterprise level thing uh you have to
make sure you have the right
authentication authorization uh this is
pretty important because when you look
at the
environment when a user makes a request
to agent it goes to task and eventually
goes to tools and makes the API call to
a service or a database if you don't
have a right authentication someone can
impersonate someone else and may be able
to steal confidential sensory
information and the second is the
authorization if you have the
authentication done properly then you
have to make sure the access control is
applied properly and this is also
important because agents have their own
roles and as a agent they can do certain
things so you have to make sure they are
not going beyond what they're supposed
to and at the same time if you have
agents which are trying to do something
behalf of another user then you have to
make sure the the user the that person's
role is enforced so if you're accessing
a database you shouldn't access anything
which the user does not have permission
to or making APA calls so so that's why
authentication authorization are super
important be that um obviously there
going to be a lot of the
issues approvals is interesting because
um in the traditional world we already
have workflows if I request for a leave
my manager will approve it it's already
built into the system but in the case of
Agents you don't need to have a human
all the time your agents can do most of
the things automatically right so there
a if you do it design it properly you
could have another agent which all it
does is just looks for approvals and
making sure the results are right and
you can also put thresholds how much
this agents can approve automatically
and you can put the proper guard rails
to make sure if it goes above a certain
uh limit it can automatically get a
human in the
loop so uh just to reiterate this one
because it's pretty important is when it
comes to authentication authorization is
not just about doing the authentication
at the point of entry at the where
you're making a request
it you have to make sure the user
identity is propagated across everywhere
if you're making a calling a task or the
task is calling a tool you have to make
sure the user identity is passed on to
the the the last point where it's
actually making a data access or making
APA calls and that point you have to
make sure you're able to enforce the
right policies and access
control and the third is um
observability so observability is pretty
important in the agent world because as
I mentioned the traditional software
once you build it it gener it just works
you just had to make sure it is uh
there's no new vulnerabilities coming in
because of some Library update or
something like that but in the world of
Agents um there are many different
variables involved one is the models
change very rapidly um you if you're
using a agent framework that is also
keep evolving right you're using third
party library that start behaving
differently um the another important
thing in an agent is is very subjective
to what the user is entering like you
may have tested with a certain
assumption mostly sunny day scenario I
want to apply for a my leave but the end
user may use entire different um uh um
text to ask the same question how do
your model is going to behave so you
have to keep monitoring to see if the
user inputs are anything that changes
how the responses are coming in and also
to make sure how much Pi data and other
confidential data is been sent out
because if you see some anomaly you to
be able to really to act upon
it
um the other thing is obviously you
can't monitor each and every request
right as a number of request increases
it's just not possible so you have to
start uh putting uh defining thresholds
and
metrics so what that really means is
uh can start
calculating counting how many failure
rates are out there once you know you
have a certain failure rat which is
within your U tolerance is fine but if
it goes above that you can automatically
create alert and look into it and the
failure rates could be because of uh Mis
Bing agent it could be a malicious users
trying to um um compromise the
system then anomal detection and is
another interesting thing I don't think
we are anywhere close to it yet uh but
is very common in uh the regular
traditional software in the security
side there always something like user
Behavior analytics where they look at
the user and see whether they have
within the U uh um standard operating
thing with agents coming in so there'll
be more and more of anomal detection
whether the agent is behaving within the
uh accepted boundaries and all those
things will end up with a security pro
fure so that will give you near real
time saying how good your agent is
actually performing in life right so
that gives you to a bit of a
confidence so to
recap uh as I said there are three
things one is preemptive have a
vulnerability eval to make sure that you
get a right risk score which gives you
the confidence whether you can promote
the uh um agent to production of you're
using third party agent whether you can
use it in your environment um
second is proactive enforcement make
sure you have the right guard rails you
have the right enforcement you have the
right sandbox so that you are able to
run the agent in a secure way um make
sure you have the right observability so
that you know at real time or near real
time how good your agent is performing
and if there are some anomalies you can
go and quickly find tune
it so um just I said we open sourced our
um Safety and Security Solutions um it's
called page. a uh security and
compliance is a pretty vast field I
don't think any single company can do it
uh so we are looking for design partners
and contributors who can help us in our
journey so if you're interested please
reach out to uh me at boscat page. or
connect me in
LinkedIn thank you
[Music]